the award-winning top cardiologists  they'll go to school for 12 years  and literally have no idea what the  heart is made of  there's a fundamental flaw of our entire  system your heart is made from food  the blood running through your veins and  arteries is made from food  your arteries themselves it's made from  food  and yet they don't get any education on  what the organs are actually made of it  is it's criminal  look at the results we've seen in the  field of medicine  every year it keeps getting worse and  the best we can come up with again  is treating symptoms right well here's  some lacinapril here's a statin  right and all of these things come with  side effects it's just treating the  symptom and it's not treating the  underlying cause